what's going on people chatter hard here
in Seattle Washington at the legendary
southern kitchen obviously I'm not here
by myself and with some talented
comedians Bo Johnson
Ralph Porter Manny Marty and kanesha
best how long even on calm enough they
don't comedy roughly what 24 25 years
now 45 years raising my kids at the same
time that's a beautiful thing
yes sir how the kids youngest would be
21 in December oldest is 30 Jesus Christ
well I don't want to ask how old you are
problem is Rob use rice sweet tea and
shea butter okay what do you guys feel
about the comedy senior like there was a
weekly rooms every night you can do a
run here and now you perform before your
aunties like lick y'all gonna come to
the house I'm gonna do a little show
really pretty much how their practice so
if you can say through the week I mean
how many times can you get up to a week
yeah up seven days a week you give them
something I mean the the range is gonna
vary let's one microphone in an
environment returning Mountains a show
in a arcade bar and there was no one no
one there they wanted to watch comedy
and see just be there bombing then the
background you'd hear
[Laughter]
all right let's talk let's talk heart of
the city that's not what this means gee
what do you expect them to get out I
want a tour and I want to go around and
I want to just make people laugh and
make people happy get a boyfriend in
every city like I love yo you know and
when you're on stage talent is
attractive you don't live what about you
you know it's you only get so many
opportunities up here and I feel like
this is kind of like the Def Jam of
today computer me where it's getting a
chance to shine and people really look
at this as putting you up on that upper
echelon so listen just go up there and
be funny so looking forward to seeing
you guys tonight at keys on main yes sir
make it do what it do man let's go
[Music]